et au moins déjà trois morts à
libreville la capitale du gabon des
soldats ont ouvert le feu sur des
manifestants après les résultats très
contestés de l'élection présidentielle
qui a vu la victoire officielle du
président sortant omar bongo le
couvre-feu a été instauré là bas le chef
de l'opposition le père mbba abessolé
arrivé deuxième de l'élection
présidentielle s'est proclamé vainqueur
de ce scrutin
pour mieux comprendre la situation
politique dans ce pays
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
richard biner et d'un lit mériaux le
problème du gabon c'est ça
quatre cents élèves par classe plus de
trente ans après l'indépendance dans le
pays qu on dit le plus riche d'afrique
tiens tellement contre pas quand même à
bien sa rédemption
l'arrivée d'une même alors fait recours
un peu les ailes après peut pas
s'asseoir à même le sol et puis être
issus les russes prennent les la bonne
idée de me laver les deux mais cette
fois sans les impacts sont venus la
copen laval les amène à la maison
l'endroit s'appelle venez voir parce
qu'on dit qu'aucun ministre n'y aurait
jamais mis les pieds
l'un de ces quartiers de briques et de
tôles surgi à libreville dans les années
70 c'est là que se sont enflammés les
premières barricades
nous voulions que mon mojito pouvoir
fort et on voit état même si à aulnoye
et changements pour que nous aussi nous
puissions vivre comme le reste est au
pouvoir il n'y avait rien faire dans ce
fief de l'opposition
80% des habitants ont voté pour le
principal adversaire du président bongo
le père mbba un prêtre qui a su les
comprendre vous avez pu vous le mal est
dans les quartiers alors qu'il y avait
beaucoup de plans d'eau d'assainissement
au niveau l'hébreu vie à aider et des
plans de construction
et si vous étiez allé à plus à
l'intérieur des pays vous verrez qu'il
n'ya pas de dos alors qu'il ya eu des
plans d'hydraulique villageoise en fait
l'argent était toujours détourné durant
les années de prospérité même les plus
pauvres pouvaient encore vivre des
miettes de la croissance aujourd'hui
n'ont plus rien que le droit de poser
cette question monsieur le président
qu'avez vous fait de l'argent du pétrole
nous les connaissons mais justement
après avoir travaillé les filles nous
allons mettre l'accent sur le
le protêt village où l'intérieur
l'arrière des pays où le couvre-feu
déclaré hier soir à la suite de violents
affrontements ne doit pas faire illusion
le malaise est profond les gabonais sont
las d'attendre